cette crise des céréales la turquie veut
jouer un rôle de médiateur pour faire
sortir les 30 millions de tonnes de
céréales bloqué en ukraine elle se dit
prête à mettre en place un corridor
maritime comme le souhaitent les nations
une
nous pouvons mettre en place un
mécanisme de collaboration entre rennes
et la russie et la turquie pour
appliquer ce plan
la turquie pense que ce plan est
réalisable
en visite à ankara le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères assure que moscou
est prête à participer et affirme que
son armée ne profitera pas de la sortie
des bateaux ukrainien pour attaquer nous
sommes prêts à garantir la sécurité des
navires qui quittent les ports
ukrainiens
et nous le ferons en coopération avec
nos collègues turcs
sépare odessa que transite la grande
majorité des céréales ukrainienne mais
mardi encore le président zelensky se
refusait à déminer les autour de ce port
par crainte que les forces russes ne
s'infiltre dans la brèche avant
l'invasion russe le 24 février l'ukraine
exportées chaque mois 12% du blé mondial
15% du maïs et 50% de l'huile de
tournesol après trois mois de guerre la
flambée des prix fait désormais peser un
grave risque de famine dans les pays qui
dépendent de ces céréales l'ukrainienne
comme en afrique ou au moyen-orient